For this problem, we have to order these six graphs by the clustering coefficient of the red node,
and the graphs will be ordered from the lowest clustering coefficient to highest.
Looking at the six graphs, we can see that c is a star network,
and star networks have a clustering coefficient of zero.
That is the lowest clustering coefficient.
You can see that d is a click to the clustering coefficient of one
as that will be the highest clustering coefficient.
Both b and f have two edges connecting the neighbors of the red node.
Let's take a look at those two.
Intuitively, since b has seven neighbors and f has five, b has a larger click and f has a smaller click,
and since they both only have two neighboring edges and b has load larger click,
and actually calculating the clustering coefficient, we can see that yes, b is smaller than f.
For a, the degree of the red node is five and there are five links between the neighbors,
so we have a clustering coefficient of half and for e degree of the red node is seven,
and they are seven links between these neighbors, so the clustering coefficient is 1/3.
So, the final answer is c, b, f, e, a, d.